in terms of ecological intelligence the
big idea is radical transparency radical
transparency is presenting to
individuals the previously hidden
impacts of the things they buy and do
and giving them choice at that moment
and it's radical because it traces those
impacts across the multitude of
environmental health and social impacts
and also does it in a way where you can
pair choices and can make a choice that
it makes a difference so I think radical
transparency is the big idea good guide
is is an exemplar of radical
transparency skin deep also so that's
the big idea there I think the big idea
in emotional intelligence is you know
that there's another very important way
to be smart